على مداري اشهر ظل سلاح الطاقه احد اوجه
الصراع بين روسيا والغرب الاوروبيون
سيتجمدون اذا التزم الغرب بعقوبات الطاقه
التي فرضها ضدنا بهذه الكلمات توعد الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتن دو ولا اوروبا في
سبتمبر الماضي انتصف الشتاء الان تقريبا
فماذا عن النتيجه يبدو انها تشير الان الى
واحد لاوروبا صفر لروسيا وذلك بحسب تعبير
احد وزراء الطاقه الاوروبيين نيكولاتيكو
الاسباب كثيره بها لاحقا التحول للغاز
المسال كان احدها وكان النتيجه زياده
الوالدات من ثلاثه 80 مليار متر مكعب في
2001 2020 الى 2011 واربعين مترا مكعبا في
2002,220 اي تعويض ثلاثه ارباع ال 80 خيار
متر مكعب التي لم تعد تتلقاها اوروبا من
خطوط الانابيب الروسيه وتاكدا لهذه
الارقام وزيرو ماليه احدى الدول كانت من
بين الاكثر تاثرا لانها كانت من بين
الاكثر اعتمادا على الطاقه الروسيه
المانيا وزيرها خرج واكد لم نعد الان
نعتمد على روسيا في الطاقه كلام هنا صادقت
عليه رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه خلال منتدى
دابوس الاقتصاديه اعلنت ان بروكسل لان نجح
حتى في التقليص الطلب على طاقه الروسيه
باكثر من 20% خلال الفتره من اغسطس وحتى
نوفمبر من العمل الماضي
ويغفر افكار
شركه الروس اتم لطاقه النوويه قد تكون
مستهدفه بالعقوبات الجديده بحسب وثائق
نشرتها واشنطن بوست الشركه تعمل على امداد
صناعه الاسلحه الروسيه بالمكونات
التكنولوجيا المواد الخام لوقود الصواريخ
وهذه الشركه تحديدا افلتت من العقوبات
الجزئيه فهناك 18 محطه نوويه روسيه
التصميم تعمل في الاتحاد الاوروبي
وبالتالي ساعدت دول اوروبيه كبريطانيا
وفرنسا في التحول للوقود النووي بدلا من
الوقود الاحفوري محطه الطاقه النوويه
البلغاريه مثلا ما تنتج خمسه وثلاثين في
المئه من كهرباء البلاد عبر استخدام
الوقود النوويه الذي توفره
حتى امريكان نفسها تعتمد على الشركه
الروسيه في حوالي ربع امداداتها من
اليورانيوم المخصصه نعم انتهى اسوا ما في
ازمه الطاقه الاوروبيه لكن الشتاء القادم
قد يكون اصعب والعهده هنا على شركه ابحاث
الطاقه
[موسيقى]